i just binged euphoria finally um
have you seen it okay you're pregnant
i
i've been watching for you
yes i saw every frame i watched every
frame of that insane show
but i like that my show is kind of like
the polar opposite
in terms of the stuff that i was like
really scandalized by like
you know at that age like a guy being
like
you know what base are you willing to go
to like that was sort of
how crazy it was like we had a book bag
with some beers or like wine coolers and
we thought we were like wow we are bad
you know and then you watch euphoria and
you're like oh snap but i really wanted
to make this show to
to look at my teenage trauma because
those that time in our lives like nobody
gets out of there without
some uh
you know without some major scars
literally and figuratively and and i
think it's important to deal with with
that trauma and that time in your life
so that you can move forward and you
have to watch the show to find out
exactly what we're talking about and i
hope it's an alluring mystery because
it is really
amazing you know what your guys's
journey is and i related
so much to it i think i've been through
pretty much the exact same thing and i
i'm so glad that you put it all into
this show and it just seems like a
really beautiful depiction
of where your life is at now i can't
recommend the show enough more
okay you're hosting the oscars this
weekend
i am freaking out regina hall and wanda
sykes okay so i did a little research um
amy and the oscars haven't had three
hosts since 1987
which was do you know
no okay it was chevy chase
goldie hawn and paul hogan
i'm shocked
i am shocked
wait first of all let us
that seems very random to me
what is your favorite
moment in oscar's history
um
i really liked this one
is that the nicole kidman
yeah that's nicole kidman yep
everyone she was clapping like that yes
yes and we were all like
why is she clapping like that like it
was so confusing but i think it was
because she didn't want to like ruin
like she was wearing expensive jewelry
but
that was a really big one that stood out
um but but also i love that like so many
hosts have been so funny
i i just i love i love comedians and
like i love uh i love their uh
the jokes like i just i remember john
stewart hosting one year and he was like
finally this year we give it up for the
unsung heroes of show business the
actors yes exactly
and you know that
there have been academy awards during
wartime um you have a political member
in your family you're such an advocate
and unafraid you're so candid and
fierce about it you know there's like
definitely
like pressure in one way to be like this
is this is a vacation let people forget
we just want to have this night but it's
like well we have so many eyes and ears
on this show i think it's a great
opportunity
to
you know at least comment on a couple
things so i actually pitched i was like
i
i wanted to
find a way to have zielinski like
you know
satellite in or make a tape or something
and just because it just because so many
eyes get on there's so many eyes on the
oscars that
um
but you know i'm not afraid to go there
uh but you know i it's not it's it's not
me producing the oscars that's why i
love you
you're i know that chris rock is someone
um i believe that chris rock is someone
who's very important to you
um yeah like a word mentor might have
been thrown around dear friend
yeah he hosted the oscars have you
talked to him about it
yes um
he is just such a lovely person and i
feel so lucky that he's my friend um
and he just he's just encouraging me
really he's just he's like you're amy
schumer you know just
uh don't forget that and like take your
time and you know do you he's just
really encouraging me to be myself and i
was just talking i was texting with
ellen but i'm going to get i'm going to
get some ellen advice i got whoopee
advice
um and whoopi i i also she you know
she's like have fun and that's really
why i'm doing it you know i kind of
because it's not you know it's not a
coveted role strangely it's not just the
oscars that's pretty hard but it's
basically putting a target on your back
but i i feel like having fun and putting
myself out there and you know and there
i couldn't be doing it with two better
people than wanda and regina i love them
so much i love the three of you and i
i'm grateful that you are putting that
target on your back because
we need it i cannot wait to see you do
this and i will just be supporting you
and cheering you on like nobody's
business
[Music]